estas familias perdieron a sus seres
queridos durante la pandemia del
covid-19 y se reunieron en Londres para
asistir al lanzamiento de la
investigación sobre el manejo de la
crisis de salud por parte del gobierno
británico
Queremos saber por qué Reino Unido y
gales estaban tan mal preparados para la
pandemia no es suficiente decir que no
sabían que se avecinaba tuvieron 10 años
para prepararse para pensar en lo que
podría pasar y salvar vidas
a pesar de haber adoptado medidas
estrictas Reino Unido registra 220 mil
muertes por covid 19 desde el comienzo
de la pandemia una de las peores cifras
de muertes en el mundo las familias de
las víctimas no serán escuchadas en la
primera parte de la indagatoria pero la
presidenta de la investigación dijo que
su sufrimiento no será olvidado
he prometido repetidamente que aquellos
que han sufrido dificultades y pérdidas
están y siempre estarán en el centro de
la investigación se reconocerá su
pérdida Durante los próximos tres años
la investigación entrevistará a expertos
en gestión de crisis jueces y políticos
entre ellos el exministro Boris Johnson
y el actual
ministro de hacienda en ese entonces
ambos Fueron criticados por su manejo de
la pandemia la investigación tendrá la
Facultad de solicitar documentos
privados como los mensajes de WhatsApp
de Boris Johnson que el gobierno se ha
negado a divulgar
está claro que el sistema no se anticipó
ni se preparó lo suficiente para la
necesidad de realizar pruebas masivas en
caso de una pandemia sin influenza se
espera que algunas de las audiencias
resulten incómodas para el gobierno
conservador en medio de un clima ya
tenso en el Reino Unido donde muchos
trabajadores de la salud todavía están
en huelga